foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Roger Bennett co-host of men in Blazers
he joins us on the program good morning
Roger how are you oh Daniel Patrick
courage
uh Mike Myers has been on the run for 45
years uh some shady shoddy police work I
was listening to that it's a long time
to be crapping your pants if you
genuinely Curtis right
did you grow up watching this franchise
in England
um we did it's What drew me to America
the number of serial killers that are on
the loose with law enforcement having no
idea of how to find them I remember
watching that from Liverpool in the
1980s and thinking that I want that kind
of life I want to go down to Lover's
Lane on a misty evening with my partner
of choice and just crap my pants uh from
the host of the popular podcast TV show
men and Blazers gods of soccer the
completely scientific 100 percent
definitive defend to the death list of
the greatest soccer players of all time
and came out today it can be purchased
online wherever books are sold the
greatest soccer player of all time is
probably Mia ham
he
over Pele and Ronaldo and Messi and
well it's not the joy of this idiotic
Pursuit I mean the answer is obviously
Christian pulisic I know you were
tracking me with your questions
gotcha I just want to be candid I'm a
Bonafide ah American loving football fan
so I do have to go Cristiano pulisic but
there's a idiotic pursuit of Wonder and
that's why we did this book it's the
World Cup that soccer themed bar mitzvah
to which the entire world is invited
replete with goals and heroes and
surplus neck tattoos and it gives you
know billions of people around the world
some of it makes Vivid memories it's
what the joy of sport is Dan it's why
you watch for the collective memories
that we make together in that instant
and to the hundred you know this is what
the book is the men and women who have
really burned themselves into our retina
it's a wonderfully subjective list it's
hilarious and you drew up your list and
then you get prepared to defend it with
the heat of
Jordan versus LeBron type argument in
soccer yeah we do on the men's side
um you know on the women's side I think
Mia ham is and certainly uh and anyone
who saw a play the undoubted goat but on
the men's side
um this Pele uh who's in here actually
on the cover you can see Maradona also
on the cover that is the one that burns
with a thousand suns and then in modern
time because there is a recency bias
that is Messi uh that tiny little
diminutive Smurf who looks like he's
just strolled out of Super Cuts but can
just unleash the kind of transcendent
play that makes you believe God has
descended to this earth and is playing
with me Immortals and of course
Cristiano Ronaldo that bottle of Draco
on the war turned into human flesh so in
modern times it's a Ronaldo Messi debate
I mean they're both Transcendent but
when I was a kid and I think this is the
one that still Reigns it is Pele on the
men's side against Diego Maradona who
1986 played England my beloved then
England it was before I was America can
um and destroyed them with two goals one
which he scored with his hand he called
it the hand of God and then when we were
reeling and just screaming about the
Injustice he then destroyed a whole team
slalom through the entire team the last
four of whom tried to decapitate him but
he just bounced off both goals won the
impudent cheek of Thomas Crown the other
just a piece of play the like of which
I've never seen outside of Gail Sayers
or Walter Payton for me it was always it
was always Maradona because he
slaughtered my heroes and and then
became a god
uh now that you're an American citizen
when the United States plays England yes
in the World Cup
who are you rooting for it's uh I often
have qualms about this I get asked this
all the time and to be an American is
the greatest joy of my life to watch you
know aside from having four kids who all
speak with American accents and an
American Wife to open up my Kerns every
morning and you know I grew up with the
Statue of Liberty in the Manhattan
skyline painted crudely on my wall I now
live here in New York and I never Tire
of that it really is something I never
take for granted so when the United
States play England as they did in the
Women's World Cup your listeners may
remember Alex Morgan who's in the book
actually in this pose drinking a cup of
tea after schooling against the English
saying solid Piers Morgan take that you
nasty little man
um I cheered with all of my heart as I
will when the United States men take the
field against Mighty England November
25th by the way Mighty England who we
faced twice before in the World Cup you
remember the first time I was on this
show 1950 yeah a little bit more of my
own hair my own teeth we won that game
one nil with minor league baseball
players in goal with another with
um a a dry cleaner Joe hate Joe gaychins
who wasn't even an American citizen
playing for us at striker we won that
game against Mighty England one nil 2010
we won that game 1-1
um so we're undefeated against England I
will cheer for the United States with
all of my heart just as you will if you
really wanted to be an American you'd
lose the accent
it's my only asset it's all I've got
going for me that and a full head of
hair Dan that's the only two like
Rebecca Lowe is trying to lose her
accent as the host of the Premier League
like I know she want to commit okay you
encourage her to do her American accent
I do answer I did actually look into
this Dan as to why I've been here now
um I moved here in
1776 and I did wonder why I still sound
like I'm you know ripped from the north
of England so I have a cousin Richard
who's been here a shorter time and he's
already sounds like Mid-Atlantic when he
speaks he speaks like you know hey guys
so everyone in England hates him because
they think he's American and everyone in
America hates him because he sounds like
he's faking an American accent and then
it was like why do I not sound American
I can't even do an American accent then
all I can say is a million dollars and I
can say hooray for Hollywood those are
the only two phrases I can say in
vaguely American and it's apparently
it's if you have a musical ear you will
naturally and adapt to
um to the land that you live in and if
you don't and I don't then you still
return so English managers when they go
and manage in Holland or France they get
mopped immediately many of them they do
their press conference in English but
there's a famous manager Steve McLaren
who went to Holland he'd been there a
month and he started to you know speak
oh yes the year you know hey the boys is
here I know a french guy I think this
guy went to France Jerry Barton is like
yeah I don't know how do you say in
English here but I can't do that yeah
but Madonna goes to London for a month
and and she's got an accent yes
well I don't know I've been here I think
Madonna and I were treated I was the
player to be named later in the Madonna
tree I think when you sent Piers Morgan
you were that you were the traitor to be
named later
so so we got you well it's not like we
were trying to export Madonna we were
willing to give Madonna to you yeah well
I think we will is that like is that
that's Madonna to England is that like
is that like Brady to temper bake just
late career there's still greatness and
you know what I threw in George Clooney
and his wife and his kids and Gwyneth
Paltrow oh
yeah and All America got was what you we
got you and that's all that we need
um the the favorite for the World Cup is
and the favorite of the world cup should
be who it's a great question so the
World Cup we're 40 days away from this
tournament uh that's the spine of my
life just an incredible uh arcing uh
presence this one is going to be in
Qatar Dan which
um is for you know it's as big as the
state of Connecticut I think smaller
than Connecticut it's an insane corrupt
Brazen piece of live golfing by FIFA who
make their decisions they're like
morality or piles of cash oh piles of
cash so it is going to be in Qatar it's
going to be slightly strange it's never
been in November before because it was
too hot to have in a desert petrol state
in the summer the two teams here I the
Julia of sport is delusion Chicago Bears
fan I Still Believe Justin Fields number
one and in that same way I have to
answer US Men's National your team God's
speed will win the thing but rationally
the two teams who look joyous
um collect like a collective fist ready
to biblically Smite all opponents
um are two great Rivals and it is Brazil
who are stacked
um in every Department wearing that
yellow
kit which is made to just shine in
glorious Technicolor and Argentina
Lionel Messi this is fifth World Cup he
said it will be his last
um he has never played well he wants to
the final many many other times just
crapping out almost the weight of the
shirt carried him down as if it was made
of chainmail watching Lionel Messi
depart World Cup in tears it's what you
think of when you hear Prince say this
is what it sounds like when doves cry I
believe this Argentina team he's playing
late on in the fullness of his life he's
thrilled he's joyous Transcendent again
Argentina Brazil and then slightly below
that level the U.S Men's National Team
good luck with the book it's great to
talk to you and I hope uh Michael Davies
is uh playing nice with you happy
birthday Todd You Beautiful human being
in America courage thank you Bob that's
uh Roger Bennett Todd's birthday was
yesterday happy birthday
happy birthday Roger Bennett uh the gods
of soccer the completely scientific 100
definitive defend to the death list of
the greatest soccer players of all time
comes out today can be purchased online
wherever books are so